proposed change to speed limits is
coming to a northwest valley area mary
jane belliesa takes us to the desert
shores community on buffalo and cheyenne
with how homeowners are responding to
the change
the temporary speed limit sign in the
desert shores community is posted as 30
miles per hour residents say it's a much
needed change from the 35 mile per hour
speed limit as many drivers are seen
speeding through the neighborhoods
to mitigate excessive speeding the city
of las vegas conducted a speed study in
the community it was temporarily reduced
to 30 miles per hour the city recommends
keeping it to 30 miles per hour to
promote safer roadways resident
catherine morales agrees 30 is fine for
around here
and people are very careful they stop if
somebody's crossing the road i don't see
any real issues there but some other
residents like david colemeyer wanted to
be 25. i think a lot of communities are
between 15 to 25.
i think there's a lot of people that are
driving very reckless around in general
you also have a lot of animals that are
running around whether it's the ducks
and so on and a lot of times you will
see
deceased animals along the roadway
jonathan alvarez oversees security for
the community's business center we have
so many walkers joggers individuals
walking their dogs wildlife that crosses
the street with the amount of lakes
there are around here so the streets are
busy i highly encourage them to keep the
speed limit as it is you can submit a
speed limit change online through the
city's website and the city will conduct
a traffic study this review includes
looking at existing conditions and
future developments reporting from
cheyenne and buffalo mary jane vallieza
8 news now
the traffic parking commission will
discuss the change in other agenda items
tomorrow afternoon at 1 p.m at city hall